what did you say your body count was
she got gulp full after her
wait what whoa whoa
welcome to relationship goals I'm Phil
Jackson your host and I'm with hey one
two funny this guy is gonna be the judge
jury and executioner relationship goals
is a tournament where couples go head to
head to see who's got the most Sally
couple if they win this they go to the
semi-final if they win a semi-final they
go to the final and if they win the
final throw them Rebecca
money you know what I mean but more
importantly asthma judge is
demonstrating they win a hundred free
fire away pizzas
and whoever wins doesn't know about me
and them was friends from time you got
what I'm saying
anyway let's go my name is Kia my name
is j200 we've been in a relationship for
10 months is your partner the one is my
partner the one
yeah I'd say so yeah yeah I just heard
there's a bag there's a fuzzle pad up
for grabs that's what I heard of money
bro I'll be nervous he's in a little bit
yeah I'm just tired it's too early for
this man hi my name is Amanda hi my name
is Leighton we have been in a
relationship for like two years I think
my partner's the one what do you think
I've been my part Mr one as well do we
argue this and we argue all the time all
the time I expect today that we're gonna
win and we're going to smash this I hope
we're gonna smash but you know I don't
trust these two presenters so anything
can happen I'm not nervous I'll be
nervous if I get some answers but I
should be getting right wrong so that's
the only thing you should be nervous
yeah I should be nervous
the boys are going to predict what they
think the girls would say ladies are
gonna have to take these noise canceling
headphones
courtesy of Z technology because you
just make your way over to the
soundproof area please because use that
cloud here this section so question one
which one of your girl's friends would
she say you're most attracted to him oh
gosh
um oh there's there's one friend that
she thinks is a longest friend so I must
say what but she knows I don't like her
so I can't at least I don't like her
personally
but she uh honestly stuttering than that
I'm gonna say someone could aim me
someone could
yeah but that's what she thinks I'm
laughing
no pressure
your girlfriend's only yeah but listen
oh this is mad okay I'll repeat that
question yeah please which one of your
girl's friends would she say you're
attracted to I hope this comes with no
repercussions but I'm going to have to
say yes
got that fair coat in there
what famous person do you think your
girl will leave you for Leighton
listen
AJ Tracy you know listen I can't believe
it but I don't look anything like me I
don't look anything like him I just
don't understand it
basically don't make your girl go tape
because it's a bit big he beats he bees
in this what about you J2 I'm saying I'm
still I'm staying with myself you know
I'm saying myself I'm not famous but I'm
pretty sure
[Music]
what's the weirdest thing you girls
actually to do in the bedroom later
blood
I don't think it's anything too weird
you know like probably like an ASLA or
choke maybe it's a little little
nothing's off limits apart from the
whole bum stuff stay away from that okay
stay away from that but I'm saying
everything else is a goalie she likes my
twos but she likes my toys okay not our
way around I don't think she'll admit
that though
so have you ever like you know sucked on
a toe yeah but it's not a thing like
that yeah
oh yeah I've been there once myself
still yeah
all right then cool ladies could put the
headphones down come back to the cup
because it's time to see what they're
saying about what you saying you guys
never heard none of that right
100 Scouts on there I was listening to
October
okay
so basically I'm gonna ask you to say in
questions that I asked your boyfriends
but use that I have to predict what they
would have said everybody ready yeah all
right then so question one I asked what
famous person
would you leave your boyfriend for and
I'm gonna go with you first Amanda who
I'd leave my boy okay
[Music]
all right so this is one of the moments
when a judge the judge jury and
executioner she said so you're saying no
one right yeah I think so
do you want to give her that or
um yes incorrect
unless you know one mate
I can concur but yeah Leighton said AJ
Tracy painfully my answer technically
told me
well the point so we've got to be fun
now guys it's okay it's okay it's okay
to be one nil down
in question two and I'm going to go with
you Kia first what is the weirdest thing
you've asked of him in the bedroom oh I
don't know
um
sucking toes
shocking toes
don't think really need the air on that
one do we uh we don't leave you out on
that one I said it is correct I'm not
getting robbed again it gets real in the
field over there what tool
big one oh look at Twisted she likes
white that's what I'm saying that's why
I said that already what is the weirdest
thing you've asked of him in the bedroom
I've asked him yeah
physics and I asked him a lot of things
she pulled out the list you see it
rolling down here
talk for anything
I just get it oh I swear what do you say
telepathy yeah he's just laying it down
like that just boom but like AJ Chase
has she ever asked you to play music No
butterflies
wait she's gonna give her answer guys go
on I'm gonna have to go with the same
answer and sometimes so what you've
asked to suck his toes not mine oh
you've asked him to suck your toes I
don't know like is it like a 69 tall
sucking session 50 50. so it's a toe off
yeah
yeah I can conquer but that is the wrong
answer incorrect
Ed light what did you say what do you
say he said with the shoulders yeah yeah
yeah yeah now we're back 50 50. all
right so this is question three this is
the most juicy question and I'm just
gonna add it in he answered the
notification one of your friends which
one of your friends would you think he
fancies okay
um
there's two people in mind here
I'm gonna go with
come on
you say you've got that many living
friends
saskia yeah all right Uma says okay yeah
that's correct this is Sasquatch I don't
remember to be happy or not
yeah
don't look at me like that all right J2
and Kia your time before time I'll
repeat the question and I would say he
took a bit longer than he did to answer
the question what she said a name oh
damn which one of your girlfriends does
J2 fancy now that's not the question is
do you think yeah
let the lady speak no he doesn't like
any of my friends so he wouldn't he
wouldn't fancy any of that so you're
gonna say no answer yeah you wouldn't
they wouldn't all right I can refer to
you back there
J2 Francis is called I don't know what
you want to do with that information but
the information is informed so what are
you like Amy in that light is that what
you're doing right now is that we're
gonna do it was saying Amy's our buff
team with a big Bunda and you know these
these little children these are changing
up the questions on that I said to him
like yo you could just say no one you
know and he was like he said oh you see
they said which one would you think that
would fancy because you always say she's
your princess don't try to explain
yourself
that's what she says
me the reason is
I'm not gonna lie I goes to him this is
how it happened correct me if I'm wrong
I said to him which one of Amanda's
friends do you fancy he won't Sasquatch
straight like no because also Amanda no
I'm Amanda no Amanda says that she is
like her prettiest friend one of our
prettiest friends I'm not gonna outlaw
guys girls you're gonna get to have your
time now guys could you go into the
soundproof area behave yourselves yeah
these scumbags I know you ain't
listening to know AJ Tracy over there
mate are you we're gonna get on to round
two
I'm ready yeah this is where he'll have
to predict what you guys say
question one I would like both of you to
look at each other for a second
if your boyfriend was single what
feature on her face which would he like
the most
I'm going to ask here wait what each
other
[Music]
hmm
actually actually I can't change it yeah
it's on your face yeah just your face no
what feature would he like
so one day yeah yeah cool
[Music]
how did you know that that's wonder you
get me
okay so I'm gonna go for
wonder what guy doesn't like it what Dad
doesn't want the Bunda
loud carefully
you know I see them Vibes and over there
to AJ you know how to see if they can
actually hit yeah AJ Tracy is so like oh
my God bro like yeah you can't hit yo
Amy yeah
all right cool question two what is the
worst present your boyfriend has ever
brought for you and will golf yes
okay so I think this was my 19th
birthday
and he literally got me like
fifteen five pound pretty little thing
dresses
no I thought I didn't know
I don't know when it's a five pound
pretty little thing dress so wait and
that's only yeah
yeah but did you wear any of them though
no oh whoops they made up for it though
by the toast no for the next birthday oh
you took me to the shark okay really he
was saving yeah that's what I'm saying
he needed to budget I don't mind I'm not
complaining what happened in The Shard I
didn't hello clarkins know what the
views were Sensational okay they use a
sensation
[Music]
what is the worst
typical but he's always got me a really
good presents so he hasn't oh he's so
good at picking but guess what you have
to pick
could the car have all been equally the
best yeah there had to be I know there
was one that you just kind of looked at
like what the [ __ ] is that
needs to be at least one that ain't as
good as doing your least favorite
oh you're trying to lose this game huh
five
four three two necklace yeah okay cool
necklace this is the final question what
did your boyfriend tell you his body
count was
and I'm gonna go for Kia first seeing if
she takes so long to answer questions
he said it was
minus 12.
okay he said it he said I'm his Fifth
Fifth Fifth side and then by 20. um um
how many followers you got two million
yeah and you're okay
um
[Laughter]
Amanda I wish I was his fifth but
I missed I don't think I'm his 50th I
know that it is there's 50. no specific
number he said it was 50.
ish thousand who knows can we have this
can we have a number let's let's have a
number I'm just gonna say 50. all right
cool boys can we have the boys back
please
first question guys if you guys were
single what part of the other
would you find most
appealing to you which part of their
body or face are you feeling the most
that's what I need you to answer and I'm
gonna go with late and first scene as he
seems so
enthusiastically it's not personal think
about it like literally right it's not
it's not personal or anything I would
say listen I'm an ass guy you know I'm
saying
so I'm gonna ask him
I'm so glad you went first that's fair
enough J2 I'm saying the same bro I'm
saying I said well this is
not specific to no one apart from her so
a guy said he liked another person
if each other no but that's that's real
man
city boys up one thousand all right then
so for question two I did ask what is
the worst present you ever got your girl
the worst present yeah he's thinking
that man don't give bad presents he's
not got me one bad present you're not
allowed to do that no more talking
please
anyway so um a necklace
okay it's probably the worst one I've
got it's probably the the cheapest thing
that I've gifted yeah that's that she
lost it it's all like a week later oh so
so the worst present she lasted
apparently it was in my car for two
weeks yeah it just went missing and then
okay so she really cared about it that's
the cheat that's the day that's probably
like the deadest thing all right what
about you
um wow what is the worst present you've
ever got Amanda definitely not that AJ
Tracy album yeah yeah very very funny
but I'm a clothing like underwear or
something underwear probably like gym
leggings or something I wasn't gonna go
for it from Victoria's Secret to gym
legs
so is it the penis or is it the gym
leggings dog because we need to
just go let's go pennies
necklace I had a feeling so yeah and
yeah the answer was you happen to go
poundland one time and get like five two
pound dresses
it was 15 actually guys it was pretty
little thing and it was the five pound
dresses oh I said oh yeah that's murder
Blood come on man
third and final question so this one's
quite light and this one obviously I'm
sure use like a very um truthful and
honest with your partner so should be a
breeze for you guys really and uh yeah
so I'm gonna go with J2 first on this we
asked your girlfriend
what did you say your body count was
she got gulp
before after her
wait what whoa whoa whatever a reverse
[Music]
I said hey [ __ ] what before after I
was like bro is that plus three since I
met her
you know what I mean I meant like the
number before I met her or like after
her like because obviously it stopped it
stopped there the numbers stopped going
up oh wait wait so including her like
because when I met her I hadn't I hadn't
done that you sound like stormzy now
yeah it's a simple answer you know it's
very simple
four four yeah yeah four including her
yeah or four not incredible including
her yeah so it's four included yeah
that's what I said so how old are you
20. so one sec let me do this match real
quick so two plus two years wait so
you're 20
and you've got how many followers 2
million so 2 million followers times 20
times it's 2002 right it's gonna say
that he said four and
um that answer was wrong because it's
fine but we can talk about that in a
minute huh no being number five
oh my dude
so who's number five
that means that the math is just not
Amy might just squeezed in there
somewhere like you get it like just like
put a movie in like just one time you
get it oh oh Leighton you've had enough
time to think no pressure
[Laughter]
that was very accurate that was very
accurate he had a bad time to think you
know yeah he was bad doing that was like
Laquisha Kenisha
all right then cool that was the correct
answer
damn
I've never said the number five to this
girl in my life the one that looks it
seems a bit muddy you know what I'm
saying so I I knew I'd stop tomorrow are
you guys ready for round three yeah
for this round I'm gonna ask you to do
something firstly if you do it you get
the point so that's one point use that
can say no I don't want to do it at any
time and then I'm going to ask you to do
something else and if you do it you get
another Point could you both please
unlock your phones and pass it to your
partner
okay
you say confident yeah
all right then cool could we type in our
partner's ex's name
in the WhatsApp and see what the last
conversation was could we do that for us
please WhatsApp yeah
deleted
but as I can see my man right here
so what now joking but it's nothing
there's nothing there
how long would you would you ask for
like two days two days
oh so you never had a combo and once at
once no
uh okay Snapchat only okay oh that's
what goes down
what's happening over there with you
guys both blocked both blocked yeah so
there's nothing there no all right so
you did it so I'm gonna give you both
the points so we write that down that's
one or two I want we to go over to
Instagram please could we go over to
Instagram oh Instagram
the direct message please could we go to
the direct message
and could we click on the general please
the general section
[Laughter]
does everything look Copa steak on
everyone's General I just was there two
things
yeah yeah that's cool this is this is
good this is so fantastic actually yeah
it is amazing can we go to the text
messages please okay okay but I'm the
one that's sweating
I don't get it bro like and again Could
you type in your ex's name how do you
spell it see I mean it won't be in the
phone because it's not there you're not
gonna make me have to go to the huh well
I don't have no messages so all right
cool so use our past round three
boringly yeah
give yourselves a clap like
[Applause]
foreign
the scores are in
and we can now declare that the winners
of this episode of relationship goals is
Amanda and Leighton wow
I'm sorry it's a good performance
for the semi-final and if you win that
you'll be in the final and if you win
that you'll get a fire away Pizza use
that passing around free
shows that use like a relationship to be
reckoned with both of you because I know
a lot of people will fail and we will
see that soon in the next episode we
shall she's got a friend called Shannon
I was teasing I'm shy stimulated
his girlfriend
um I'll look forward to meeting you at
the gym
um yeah it'll be great to see you and
make sure you wear those leggings can
you order me a pair too I'll send you
some cash send me your details see you
soon bye
long day